$207,000
in the last 90 days trading one setup
only on the 5-minute time frame taking
just one trade per day. I wasted years
with ICT. Endless concepts, multiple
time frames, struggled a lot to be
consistent. Then I simplified everything
to one mechanical setup and this
happened. Now I'm going to show you the
exact strategy step-by-step and I'll be
using the last 4 days of real trades. No
cherry-picking, no setups that happen
only once per month, only trades that I
took. So let's get straight into it.
This trade that I took today. This is
yesterday. This is on Friday and this is
on Thursday. Step one, every day before
market opens I check my custom EMAs.
These are higher time frames EMAs
directly showing up on my 5-minute
chart. Big institutions are monitoring
these EMAs every day. And at the end of
this video I will show you how to get
these custom EMAs directly on your chart
completely for free. So if these EMAs
are stacked and pointing up, I'm only
looking for buys. If these EMAs are
stacked and pointing down, I'm only
looking for shorts. When these EMAs are
flat or mixed, I don't trade at all.
That's my entire bias defined in 10
seconds. No need for complexity, no need
to switch between 10 time frames. Step
two, I look for a fair value gap inside
a counter trend. So today we are
obviously bullish. The counter trend
will be bearish. That's why we have here
this bearish fair value gap inside the
price. Step three, if we inverse this
fair value gap, I would be going in for
continuation and target previous
liquidity.
Since we have here no previous
liquidity, I usually be targeting a two
to one risk reward ratio. The stop loss
goes under the swing low.
And bang, TP hit. This was the trade
from today. I made 4K with it. Now let's
go to yesterday. The price is above the
EMAs and they are pointing up.
My bias is bullish for the day. This was
the first step. The second step is I
wait for the New York session to start
and I wait for a counter trend to form.
I need to see a bearish mini trend and I
want to see a fair value gap inside this
bearish counter trend. So we can see
right here that we formed a fair value
gap inside the counter trend
and we are simply waiting for the price
to break through this fair value gap and
to inverse it. This is the step three.
You can see here that we inverse this
fair value gap. We go in. The stop loss
is at the swing low and if our liquidity
level is too close, we simply target two
R. Here's the replay of this trade.
So a full TP hit and this was a trade
from yesterday. Also made 4K with it.
Now let's go to the day before. You can
see the EMAs here are pointing up. Our
bias will be bullish. This is the first
step. Now we wait for the market open
and we need to see a counter trend. So I
need to see a bearish trend and a fair
value gap forms inside a bearish trend
like you see here.
This is a fair value gap and the price
immediately inverse it. I go in. The
stop loss under the swing low and I
don't believe we had a liquidity to
target this day. No, so I targeted two
Rs.
Let's see how this trade will play out.
So this was a stop loss hit as you can
see here on the 10th. I lost 2K. This is
what I want you to know about the
strategy. This is not a 100% win rate
strategy. There is no such thing. This
was a losing day. I simply took the L,
closed my laptop and called it a day.
Now let's get to the day before. You can
see here that the EMAs are stacked and
pointing up.
I will be only looking for buys.
Let's wait for the market open. So we
are done with the first step which is
defining our bias. We will be bullish
today. Now I want to see
a retracement or a downtrend.
So we can see clearly that we formed a
fair value gap inside this counter
trend. This is for step two.
Step three is I wait for the price to
inverse this fair value gap so we can go
in and trade the continuation.
Make sure if you see a fair value gap
formed here, then we take the last fair
value gap that was inversed and we
simply ignore this. It's not the case
here, so we wait for the price to break
this fair value gap and to inverse it.
Like you see here. We did inverse this
fair value gap. We go in. Stop loss
under the swing low and we target this
previous liquidity that we have here.
Let's play the trade out and see what
happened.
Directly a full TP hit. This was a three
R trade. I believe, yeah. I made 5.9K
with it. You don't realize what I showed
you right now. I just showed you four
back-to-back trades which has only one
stop loss and three TPs. You have 3%
here minus 1% that's 2% plus here we
have 2% plus 2% that's 6% in only four
trading days with full mechanical
strategy. You don't need to be glued all
the day in front of the charts and most
importantly, these are absolutely not
cherry-picked trades. I did gave you
four trades back-to-back days. Now let's
do a recap of the strategy. The first
thing you want to do is to look at these
custom EMAs. If they are stacked and
pointing up, you only buy.
If they are stacked and pointing down,
you only sell. If they are sideways, you
simply don't trade. This is the first
step, the bias. The second step is you
wait for a counter trend to form. Then
you want to see a fair value gap formed
inside this counter trend. This is step
two.
For step three, you want this fair value
gap to be inversed. You go in. You put
your stop loss under the swing low and
you target next liquidity. If you find
no previous liquidity to target or this
next liquidity that you see is too
close, you simply target two R. If you
can do this every single day without
hesitating, without FOMOing, without
revenge trading, I promise you you will
have numbers like this. Now as I
promised you at the beginning of the
video, I will show you how to get the
custom EMA on your chart. You can go on
your TradingView and search for this
indicator. 10 in one different moving
average. You click on it, then you go in
and check the first three select EMAs
and put the value here to 50.
The first one will be the 15-minute EMA,
the second one will be the 30-minute EMA
and the third one will be the 1-hour
EMA. Then choose whatever color you
want. Here you can see that these EMAs
are exactly like mine. If you found this
video helpful, make sure to like,
subscribe, drop your comments down below
and follow me on Instagram. I drop
videos every week on NQ showing you my
trades and showing you my strategy that
can bring me numbers like this. Thank
you so much and let's meet next time.